facebook makes convnets return to glory
a new text-to-speech model lets you
speak any language you want and
automated music transcription gets a
boost welcome to ml news
[Music]
and welcome to ml news it is so great to
have you here how are you doing i hope
everyone's okay let's dive into the
first story facebook research publishes
a paper called a convnet for the 2020s
in which they take on the notion that
somehow transformers are to replace
convnets for computer vision they make
the argument that rather than the
attention mechanisms in transformers it
is due to some more kind of subtle
improvements that the transformer
architectures have over classical
convnets now they show that if they
systematically include the best of these
changes then they can make a convnet
that performs as well or better than
vision transformers this results in the
following graphics starting from the
original resnets in the bottom left
corner and comparing to various vision
transformer architectures on imagenet 1k
and imagenet 22k that allows also
pre-trained models now this has
obviously garnered quite some attention
the code is actually available online if
you want to try but for example lucas
buyer has pointed out that if you do
compare to vit that is trained let's say
properly with augmentations and so on
then the convnext isn't that far ahead
the graphic should look more like this
and ross whiteman maintainer of a
popular library of computer vision
models also points out that if you take
a resnet and you train it properly then
you will be at the level of like a small
conv next and that would mean that the
resnet bubble itself would also be
lifted to about the 82 mark right here
another comment came from minshin tan
who augments the graphic by efficient
net v2 on imagenet 1k and 22k which
would result in the following graphic so
safe to say what we can read from this
is that the market for models in
computer vision isn't decided at all yet
the race is still wide open and it seems
like we can achieve comparable
performances with various different
architectures now maybe it is the case
that all you need to do is just take a
big model with lots of parameters and it
doesn't really matter what you do as
long as you do a certain number of
things right on the other hand it could
also be that we haven't yet come across
the ultimate architecture yet and
there's still an architecture out there
somewhere waiting to be discovered to
dominate computer vision once and for
all only time will tell for now go and
check out the code of connext it is on
github interestingly meta research still
uses the facebook research github handle
there's been a paper making the rounds
called auditing saliency cropping
algorithms that investigates popular
saliency cropping methods saliency
cropping is what these platforms for
example twitter do to pictures in order
to make them fit the predefined format
for example the picture here on the
right is in fact much longer if you
click on it yet in order to fit the
familiar twitter timeline he needs to
crop it somewhere so these platforms
they try to decide what is the most
salient what is the most interesting
point in a picture and they try to crop
towards that rather than just always
cropping to the top or to the bottom or
to the middle now for a bit more
background people in the past have often
criticized the saliency cropping
algorithm due to them being said to have
certain preferences for certain skin
tones and also exhibiting a phenomenon
where they would focus on the non-face
parts especially of women there's this
famous example of two politicians one
light skin one dark-skinned and no
matter how you order them if you make a
long picture that has one at the one end
and one at the other end and then a
white area in the middle the different
algorithms would choose to focus on
different faces repeatedly this paper
systematically investigates the saliency
cropping algorithms of twitter google
and apple in both skin tone differences
and also with respect to the phenomenon
of what they call the male gaze now they
make a big deal out of this idea of the
male gaze which is a concept that
essentially says society will reorder
itself will build products will make
media to represent the male view of the
world specifically how men look at women
mostly the narrative is around
objectification and when people shared
anecdotal evidence of twitter cropping
pictures of women in the following way
this played into this narrative of the
male gaze so the hypothesis would be
that through whatever mechanism mostly
how the training data is collected and
so on the algorithm would learn to focus
on the non-phase part of female bodies
and therefore reproduce the male gaze
that built the data set or built the
society where the algorithm was trained
in obviously that would be a problem and
discovering an effect like this would be
quite interesting the paper noticed that
the anecdotes posted the examples posted
of this happening were mostly women on
runways in red carpet type situations so
they collected a data set of pictures
like these and ran them through the
saliency algorithm and surprisingly they
discovered that whenever the algorithm
did not focus the face itself it would
actually focus mostly on some sort of
corporate logos in the background now
these corporate logos happen to be very
often not on face level or at least the
ones that the algorithm chose to focus
on would not be on face level resulting
in a non-face-centric crop now there's
two ways to go from here one way would
be to say ah look at this the algorithm
is kinda crap it misses the face a lot
of the times it focuses on these logos
and that gives the appearance of the
algorithm objectifying women or having
anything of that effect in there and
therefore we can discard the male gaze
hypothesis or whatever we started with
the paper doesn't do this however
instead it makes a big point of calling
these things male gaze-like artifacts or
male gaze-like effects essentially
retaining the opinion or the appearance
that this is still problematic in
regards to this effect so instead of
saying it's actually not sexist it's
just crap they do work place and simply
characterize it as whatever they want
dash like
and this i find to be a little bit
worrisome in my opinion this clearly
shows that the authors were out to find
this effect they were out to find
something of this nature and the data
just didn't back that up and honestly
given how many ways you can slice and
dice data and do analyses i'm quite
astonished that they didn't find
anything that they could show as
evidence for that but then instead of
discarding they choose to keep this
hypothesis in there and they choose to
call the artifacts they find male gaze
like now the paper itself can do a lot
of hedging the paper can say well we
described what this is right we never
meant male gaze we meant male gaze like
they can hedge by saying well our paper
is mainly about the
methods of testing this it's not really
about the result
it's more about the how we collect the
data set and so on so you can construct
a paper that no one can essentially
criticize you until you can just
backtrack into your i did nothing wrong
and then when you promote the paper you
can be a bit more loose right still not
saying anything wrong you can be a bit
more loose you can just kind of leave
away things because you know you're just
promoting it it's social media or a talk
or whatnot and whenever you get
criticized you can say well we clearly
defined things in the paper i'm sorry
twitter is a short medium and so on and
then maybe other people come and and
pick it up and they just see kind of the
title maybe a little bit of the abstract
maybe a little bit of the promotion and
in the eyes of most people out there you
will have successfully uh reached the
original hypothesis now i'm not saying
investigating these things is uh not
good or anything like this i'm happy
that there are people who do these types
of investigation i'm very happy that
people publish look here is how to
collect a data set and here is how to
study these things but if the
experiments had turned out the other way
like if they found that the most salient
point after the algorithm would always
be on women's private parts or something
like this do you think the paper would
have sounded the same do you think the
paper would be of you know we just want
to get our methodology out there we
don't really it's not really about the
results or so on like nah nah no way as
i said the paper also does a systematic
investigation into how the algorithms
focus on skin tones the results there
are mixed as well but i'll leave it at
that i don't want to criticize this
paper super particularly even though i
do think it is politically motivated but
it's just difficult to evaluate things
when it is quite clear the authors
wanted to find a certain thing
there's a new text to speech system
called your tts towards zero shot
multi-speaker text-to-speech and
zero-shot voice conversion for everyone
now this system reaches state of the art
in zero shot text to speech and it is
quite intricately trained but what you
can do is you can have your voice say
something in a completely different
language so i'm gonna try this right
here hello and welcome you're listening
to ml news all right so now i'm gonna go
to french and i don't actually have to
say the same thing in french
no
uh
what's the music playing in the
background
all right well in any case it sounds
pretty good so and it's really fast the
code is available a link to the collab
and everything give it a try
mt3 is a system for multi-task
multi-track music transcription it is
part of google's project magenta that
applies machine learning to the arts
this is also available and it's again
pretty cool what it can do there is a
hugging face space where you can upload
your own audio and have it transcribed
and there is this demo on reddit
[Music]
yes it is midi like it's not supposed to
sound the same but it does transcribe
the music into multiple tracks into
multiple parallel tracks it's really
hard task and it's really cool that this
is sort of possible out of the box model
is available
on github you can check it out
quartz writes china's new algorithm
rules are at odds with its tech giant's
business models this is an article
detailing china's new rules for what
they call algorithms which are
essentially recommender systems so the
new rules mean that algorithm providers
need to proactively spread positive
energy
ensure their algorithms are for good and
they curtail algorithms for promoting or
causing excessive spending or for the
algorithms to lead to developing an
addiction to the platforms this is
obviously targeted at many of the newer
social media systems that explicitly use
recommender systems to drive most of
their business now while this seems like
a pretty unprecedented move especially
for china the article also says that
some argue that the impact might not be
so large because the rules essentially
only require that users have the ability
to opt out and a lot of users simply are
not going to do that but it's pretty
cool that at least you have the option
to do so and honestly in my opinion i'd
much rather have an opt out feature that
is like buried somewhere in three layers
of setting than every single website
asking me whether and what cookies i
want that's just annoying not saying i
don't see the reasoning behind the rules
existences i'm just saying is freaking
annoying
kashani and amir ivory release
deep learning interviews hundreds of
fully solved job interview questions
from a wide range of key topics in ai
this is version 2 and it includes it is
a giant pdf that includes questions and
solutions you can see it's over
360 pages from all disciplines of ml so
if you're looking to prepare for job
interviews or simply up your skill a
little bit in a different area of ml
this might be a neat resource for you
[Music]
all right we'll come to some helpful
material helpful libraries helpful
things that i found deep checks is a
tool for validating machine learning
models and data it essentially acts a
little bit like a unit test framework
for machine learning code dagshub is a
platform to version data models
experiments and code they claim to have
a github-like experience for machine
learning now while i enjoy the presence
of yet another ml ops system and the
launch of release 2 which also
integrates data labeling into their
system the coolest thing about this is
their background on the website see
follows your mouse and this is just cool
and i think every time you enter you get
like a new color look at that
wow
it's completely dark when you start so
you don't you never expect it and then
watsa bayesian modeling and computation
in python is a free book that is
available online about
bayesian modeling and computation in
python
it is on amazon if you want the
hardcover but you can just read it
online if you want to
mlcontests.com is a website that just
keeps track of machine learning contests
for example on kaggle ai crowd and more
rayscorch is a wrapper around scorch to
use ray for distributed training now
what is scorch you ask good question
scorch is a rapper around pytorch in
order to make it compatible with sk
learn rumble is a database that is built
on top of apache spark and hdfs and it
allows you to feed in json and process a
lot of data very efficiently with a
json-like
query language so you can query
heterogeneous data you can query nested
data and it will scale from your laptop
all the way up to data centers it's open
source you can check it out jax models
is a github repository that says it's an
unofficial repository of jack's
implementations of deep learning models
it is a young project but it does have
some models inside and it is growing if
you're into jax and you're looking for a
model maybe you'll find it here s3 prl
is a library to process speech
specifically a self-supervised speech
pre-training and representation learning
toolkit alright that was it for the
helpful stuff i hope some of you have
been helped by the helpful stuff
i've come across this blog post right
here explaining alpha zero and i found
it to be very understandable and
instructive so if you wanna get into
alpha zero or any of the related
algorithms maybe give this blog post a
read it explains everything pretty well
and understandably and it's a good first
contact with these kinds of algorithms
if you don't know yet exactly what they
do the blog post is by josh varti and
i'll link it in the description
sherbank ai have been making some
progresses into large models recently
they release rudolph after rudoli
rudolph is what they call a hyper modal
transformer they call it hyper modal
because it has multiple multimodal
components the first component is a text
to image part and the second component
is an image back to text part with this
they can do various tasks such as visual
question answering they can do abstract
like visual reasoning and many more
things obviously they can also do
whatever the individual parts can do
such as image generation from text like
dali or image compatibility tasks such
as clip the model tokenizes images into
latent tokens using a vqgan and from
there on it essentially treats it as a
sequence of token models the outputs of
this models are pretty impressive and
the code as well as the small models are
available online and there's even a
collab for you to try it out the collab
itself is also a little bit of a write
up of how the model works so if you're
interested in that give it a try
and lastly jeff dean has a rather long
blog post on a 2021 summary of google
researchers advances it's divided into
five trends for example more capable
general purpose models more efficient
models and so on now a lot of it is not
only geared towards google research but
also google products and i won't go into
the blog post itself here but if you're
interested this is a good overview over
at least a slice of the ml research
landscape in 2021 and that was already
it for ml news thank you so much for
tuning in for being here everything i've
mentioned is in the description i wish
you all the best see you next time bye
bye
[Music]